a JavaScript's date constructor helps
with parsing managing and displaying
dates there are a few ways to make a
date object the quickest is to make the
objects for the current date and time so
here's how you would do that do VAR v
1.is to new date and I can log that and
see what that's going to look like it's
due to string to convert it to a string
and then if I run that you'll see in the
console the date down below now I can
also convert that to a date string and
then it's just going to show if you look
in the console it's just going to show
the date or I can do to time string if I
run that in the console you can see it's
just going to show the time or I can do
to UTC string and it's going to show it
without my time zone in GMT so if you
look back to the to time string it's
always going to show the time zone of
the browser so I am in the EDT time zone
so that's what it's going to show the
time in okay we can also make ad object
a different way so we can pass in the
year month day hours minutes seconds and
milliseconds so let's try that and
JavaScript the months start at 0 so
January is going to be 0 February is
going to be 1 March is going to be 2 so
all the dates are just off by one and
here I didn't even have to put two
string you can just log the the date and
it's going to give this format but if
you redo to string it's going to be a
little more readable and you can see we
have the month as one and then it's
showing February
like I was saying it starts at zero now
we can also create dates with a time
value so we can do new date and then
we're going to just enter a time value
such as and this is a time that's the
number of milliseconds since January 1st
1970 and that that's when you when
you're entering a time value that's what
that time that number is okay let's try
a bigger number there and I'm going to
run that okay so you can insert these
milliseconds and you can see the date
down below now the last way you can
create a date is with a date/time string
there are a lot of options for that so
let me show you a few so you can put in
a date in a lot of different formats so
I'm going to try it this way you can see
I have the month day year and time and
we can console that log that I run that
you can see below well here's a few
other ways you can change this you can
just put just the numbers 2015 do three
for the month and then the day at the
end and then we can do it that way or we
can only put the year and month we don't
need the day right here or we can just
put the year or we can do in a different
format we can do it with some slashes
like that so that's the month and the
day and then you can put the year after
it or you can actually type out the the
month but we can do Mar 25
the month and the day can be in any
order
also the commas don't matter you can put
commas or you could not put commas or
you can spell out the month completely
so it takes a lot of different formats
here so after you've created a date you
can there's a lot of methods to get
information console.log and then I'm
going to do get date if you got the pass
on the date they're going to get the
date from so d4
I get date look at the the console the
date when you do get dates going to be
that day of the month so it's gonna be
25 or you can do get day which is it
going to be the weekday as a number so
six means it's going to be the sixth day
sunday starts at zero and then the sixth
day is going to be Saturday there's a
lot of other ones you can do get full
year get hours get milliseconds get
minutes get month get seconds get time
yeah if you get time it's going to be
the milliseconds since January 1st 1974
all those things I just mentioned there
setters waive the getters and setters so
we can do D for a set year and we can
set a new year so I'm going to set that
to 2020 and now we can do console dot
log beef before dot to string and we run
that oh I forgot to put the parentheses
at the end okay so we have the the day
has a new year now you can set the day
the full year the hours in milliseconds
the minutes anything like that and now
lastly I'm just going to show you how
you could use the date object to figure
out elapsed time so let's do a program
here first we have to figure out what
the start time is so I'm just going to
create a new date and then we are going
to call a function here which I'm just
going to call do something which I have
to create a minute here now we have to
get the end time so what what's the time
after we've done something and then we
just have to figure out the elapsed time
between the start and end time so VAR
elapsed so we're going to use one of
those getters get time and we're going
to subtract start dot
get time time from the end time - the
start time is going to be the elapsed
time console.log the elapsed time and
this is going to be in milliseconds so
now I just have to create the do
something function and the point of this
is just to do something that takes time
here so we're going to create a for loop
and we're just going to do some number
in here
well I is less than that number we're
going to just increment I and this for
loop isn't going to have anything in it
so let's run this and see what happens
and we have an error so let's see oh I
forgot to put my curly braces after the
for loop that was a pretty easy thing
here okay let's run that again okay so
you can see that took one millisecond
you can see at the bottom there so let's
create add a few more zeros to that and
run that again and now we're down to 15
milliseconds you can see that's 15
milliseconds they add a few more zeros
the elapsed time was 1235 milliseconds
so that's the way you can just use the
day object to find out a elapsed time
okay thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good